you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
lava from la palma's volcano reaches the
sea sparking fears of toxic gas being
released into the atmosphere
the un's climate chief tells sky news
it's unlikely china will bring forward
its zero carbon target date in time for
the cop26 summit
and bangkok on alert as a tropical storm
leaves much of thailand underwater
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now nine days after it first erupted
lava from the cumbre vieja volcano on
the canary island of la palma has
reached the atlantic ocean there are
fears that as the lava which is at a
temperature of around 1200 degrees
celsius reacts with the sea water it
could create toxic hydrochloric acid
vapor now as a precaution everyone
within a two mile radius of where the
lava met the sea has been told to stay
indoors well in a moment we'll hear from
an expert in the environmental impact of
volcanic gases but first sky's becky
cottrell is live for us on la palma
tonight so becky tell us what the
situation is like there now
well hopefully just behind me you can
see all of that smoke and steam rising
off the water as you mentioned that lava
is incredibly hot and when it hits the
water it creates a thermal shock also
what is happening is that as the lava is
cooling and hardening on the water it's
created what i would describe as a
headland here they're calling it a lava
vent that's sort of expanding out into
the sea and hardening and creating a new
structure now that steam that is coming
off of the water as you mentioned that
is toxic it contains hydrochloric acid
and if you breathe it in or get it in
your eyes it is dangerous and that is
why the people nearby have told been
told to stay inside now we have just
been through those towns people are not
staying inside but to be honest at the
moment it doesn't seem that they really
need to the government has said that the
air quality is still good i'm sure as
you can tell it's extremely windy and
the wind is blowing that gas away from
the towns rather than towards them so
for now they are safe but obviously the
concern is the wind could change and the
air quality could also change
becky thanks very much indeed well let's
get the thoughts then now of dr evgeny
ileanskaya from the university of leeds
school of earth and environment and
whose work focuses on volcanic gases and
their impact on the environment so
thanks very much indeed for talking to
us today so give us a sense of the
impact of a volcanic eruption on the
environment then
yeah volcanic eruptions um they can emit
huge quantities of potentially toxic
elements
and in fact individual eruptions can
match
total anthropogenic emissions of some
polluting chemicals
um from entire countries large countries
such as china and the usa so you can
imagine living downwind of such a
volcano it can potentially have really
harmful consequences to health
so obviously there's the impact of those
toxic gases being released into the
atmosphere does that have an effect on
global warming can it have an impact on
climate change
no it doesn't it's not from eruption
such as this one um the chemicals that
we should be concerned about have an
impact on health and air quality but not
climate
and what about the fact that the lava
has now reached the sea in la palma
what impact could that have on the
biodiversity of the land that's being
covered but also the seabed
yeah it's an interesting question it's
something that just hasn't been studied
very well at all
um
we we know from studies in hawaii where
there are common events such as this one
um that the chemistry is very
complicated and there are and it's
actually quite different from eruptions
that just happen on land
for instance we get a lot more emission
of certain trace elements such as copper
and what impact that has on the
biodiversity we just don't know um there
are indications um so some of these
trace elements are very beneficial in
small quantities but the boundary is
very easily crossed into them being
toxic so i believe it just remains to be
seen and something that we need to study
much better
well dr evgenya ilyanskaya thanks very
much indeed for your expertise we
appreciate it thank you
thank you now the un climate change
chief has warned that china is unlikely
to bring forward its net zero carbon
emissions target from 2060 in time for
november's cop26 summit patricia
espinoza shared her rather gloomy
forecast with our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter who
reports now from milan where this week's
youth cop event is continuing
patricia espinoza leads the global
response to climate change at the united
nations and with the crucial cop 26
climate summit in glasgow just weeks
away she's involved in an urgent
diplomatic effort to get countries to
make further cuts to their carbon
emissions
john kerry has previously said that if
china
doesn't move its net zero target from
2060 to 2050
the efforts of the rest of the world
could be in vain
does the fate of our planet rest on
china's shoulders
china has uh committed to
the way they they put their their pledge
was
before 2060. so you think it could be
2050
i hope so i think maybe they are not
there yet
at this moment but i i certainly hope
they could bring that
date forward
are you hoping for that by cop
by cop
i think that will be difficult but at
least to have a plan
to
to do that to come forward with more
ambitions and disease
in the coming years but will that be
enough for the rest of the world to keep
1.5 alive every day every moment that
that passes the the window
is
smaller and this is why glasgow is so
important what keeps you up at night
in relation to the climate crisis
there are so many
so many
things
but
yeah
what what i would say
probably is
the
the possibility that people
would get so discouraged
that they would
kind of
give up
we cannot give up
we cannot give up
there are many obstacles to overcome if
the international community is to make a
success of cop 26.
the science is increasingly clear
whatever the challenges more must be
done and quickly
hannah thomas peter sky news in milan
some on today's other climate news now
and sakia starmer says that labour is
committed to a green new deal that would
reduce the majority of the uk's
emissions by 2030. during his first
in-person conference speech the labour
leader set out how his party would
tackle climate change he also outlined
plans to retrofit homes to make sure
they're properly insulated and energy
efficient
emissions from homes have increased
and we have the least energy efficient
housing in europe
so it will be labor's national mission
over the next decade to fit out every
home that needs it to make sure that it
is warm well insulated and cost less to
heat and we'll create thousands of jobs
in the process
the us government has declared the
ivory-billed woodpecker and 22 other
species extinct
scientists from the u.s fish and
wildlife service say they've exhausted
all efforts to find the 23 species it's
thought more birds and fish could
disappear due to rising temperatures and
habitat loss caused in part by climate
change
the government has announced plans to
allow scientists to use gene editing to
develop new strains of crops scientists
say it could breed stronger healthier
plants that can withstand extreme
weather brought about by climate change
but the farming charity the soil
association has warned it's not a
long-term solution and could cause
environmental damage
thailand is used to heavy rains during
the monsoon months but the effects of
this year's wet season have been
exacerbated by a particularly intense
tropical storm now it's left much of the
country particularly the north
underwater and now the capital bangkok
is on alert
what provinces representing 40 percent
of thailand have been hit after the
tropical storm dianmu brought flash
flooding as well as heavy rain now the
yellow areas that you can see here
are the 30 provinces that have been
affected and most of the flooded areas
are agricultural and low lands
nearly 200 000 households across the
country have been impacted by the floods
and at least seven people have died and
one person is still missing skies
siobhan robbins has more
in flood hit thailand
rescuers
water has cut off the roads so this is
the best way to get supplies to the
stranded
the pilot has a bird's eye view of the
devastation
here businesses schools and homes
inundated by heavy rain
rain which elsewhere overwhelmed a
reservoir sending torrents into the
communities below
flood water doesn't reach inside the
house we're still able to cook and eat
there but going in and out of the house
is difficult i just came back with the
rescue workers and went out to get some
food i had to wait for more than two
hours before i could come home
almost 200 000 households have been
affected by the floods
northern and central parts of the
country so far bearing the brunt
a tropical storm in monsoon season
causing misery for thousands and
threatening to flood some of thailand's
most precious historical sites
over the last few months
the last storm brought a lot of water
which surprised us
we are prepared enough
today the prime minister has been to see
some of the damage
thailand's king and queen have also sent
aid to the needy
flooding is common in rainy season
but the ferocity of this storm took many
by surprise
villages have become lakes
homes isolated islands
and in some areas the water is still
rising
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'm going to be joined by climate
activist climate justice activist there
is a gagy and sam hall director of the
conservative environment network there
they are standing by we're going to be
discussing whether the planet would be
better off under a labor government and
if gene editing could be part of the
solution to climate change
[Music]
okay what have we left on
[Applause]
well it's a start
well we wanted to create a character
that really tackled some very difficult
issues in the environment and climate
change but in a really
fun and entertaining and um it being
light
for the kids to really engage with obkey
and to find some really good solutions
to the difficult subjects that we have
to talk about on climate change
i actually found and saw what the
environment and climate change is doing
to the ocean so for me i wanted to
create this character that actually is
based in the sea because i've seen what
climate change has done to our marine
life and
our oceans
what op he's trying to do with the tasks
that he has and
the topics for example what you just
showed on the clip was switch it up
which is the first episode and that is
showing kids that you can save energy in
your house by turning off
the lights and electrical compliances
that don't need to be on
to save energy and it's finding these
topics
and explaining them in a fun and
environmental way so that the kids can
engage and actually
in the end um with their parents and
with their friends and communities to
actually get involved for example also
one of the topics that we have is
planting an insect garden and so you
know that is something that they can all
do together and it's not so scary we're
trying to take that away and make it
positive and find solutions for climate
change
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
stuff yeah
thursday will be a windy day with
showers or longer spells of rain
a band of rain heavy at times will push
southeastwards across england and wales
although the far south east may stay dry
scotland and northern ireland and
ireland will have a mix of sunny spells
and heavy blustery showers
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high the unsettled and rather windy
conditions will help maintain low levels
of air pollution on thursday
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate justice activist days agaji and
sam hall director of the conservative
environment network so good evening to
both of you good to have you both on
so let's go to our first topic and we
heard kirsten earlier in the show laying
out his climate proposals so we're
asking would labor being in charge be
better for the planet so days let's take
a look at what he said at 28 billion
pounds a year for the next decade to
tackle climate change there's also money
for green steel money for retrofitting
homes to make them more energy efficient
so does that sound good to you
yeah i think that labor would be an
amazing government to forward the
climate change agenda um as we have the
tories currently now um we see that
there's a lot of talk about being
climate leaders but we're still yet to
see them achieve their own targets um
this is an issue and we need to start
seeing it as an issue um i think that
kia stamina today within his speech
speaking upon things like having a clean
air act um having a um like bringing in
insulation which seems to be really hot
topic amongst the protests that's been
happening um i do think that having the
labour party and what they're promising
could be really amazing for this country
but then also i think there's a little
bit of hesitance around their labor
party as a at the moment they're very
fractured party um and i think they need
to really work on some of the internal
um conflicts and come together so they
are stronger and better for the next
election
sam you're a conservative so what do you
make of that criticism that the tories
are all talk and no action and that
would you agree
that labour's plans do look better for
the planet
well i disagree firstly the um the
conservatives are all talk and no action
yes there are some strong targets that
the government's put in place but you
have also seen alongside that deep
emissions cup particularly in the power
sector where coal has gone from over 30
percent of our electricity mix down to
almost zero uh in the space for a few
years renewables have ramped up we've
got the biggest offshore wind sector in
the world so i don't think that's the
fair criticism in terms of labour's
proposals i actually do think that there
is a case for more spending on climate
change and i hope that the chancellor
addresses that in the comprehensive
spending view i think it will help
people install insulation which will cut
their energy bills i think it could also
help us get a first move advantage in
number of green industries but i
disagree that this should be a
predominantly publicly financed and
funded transition i think there's a huge
wall of private capital out there
waiting to invest in green industries
and green infrastructure look at the
offshore wind sector for example which
has been built predominantly through
private finance i worry that with some
of labour's proposals you risk crowding
out the private sector and you don't
fully capitalize on the innovation the
cost reductions which only come from
private sector competition and i think
that's why the conservative approach was
there's still more to do and i'm not
here to say the government's yet on
track to its targets i think that
approach ultimately is the one that will
get us to net zero quickest and with
popular consent okay days what do you
make of that
well i just don't i also i don't really
agree with you
i think that um within the last um
reports that we got from the climate
change committee it is showing that the
government is not on their targets and
they are seriously lacking behind um i
do worry about putting the hands of our
future in business as we can see um
there is a lot of issues with business
not being accountable for the climate
catastrophes they are cool saying um and
there needs to be really strong
government in this i believe
and what about some of the other
criticisms sam that's leveled at the
government at the green homes grant that
was scrapped after six months the the
fact that the cambo oil field could get
the go-ahead
the
lack of ban on new oil and gas projects
do you think that's undermined the
government's green credentials and how
important is that given that we're going
into cop in november with the uk's hosts
well on the on the green homes grant i
mean it's important to note that that
was introduced as a short-term stimulus
measure to create jobs and get the
economy going post-covered there is a
need desperately for more energy
efficiency funding as i as i said and i
hope that in the comprehensive spending
review and the heat building strategy
which the government is shortly due to
publish there will be more funding to
give households vouchers and other
incentives to insulate their homes that
i agree that is a missing piece at the
moment and but i don't think it was
right to look at the green homes grant
for for doing that project within that
policy
in terms of oil and gas you know we are
going to see a decline in oil and gas
use as a result of our net zero target
the climate change committee thinks
about 70 by 2050 i do that i think we
need to look at you know how how the oil
and gas sector is going to wind down and
how we need to instead ramp up green
energy to take its place um you know the
government has said there's going to be
this climate checkpoint and which will
make sure that any new oil and gas
licenses are compatible with our targets
and i think that's the key need to get
that policy right so that we are still
in line with our net zero target even
even if there is going to be ongoing oil
and gas which we do still need okay
let's move on to our second topic shall
we because the government is saying that
it will allow scientists to explore gene
editing to develop different strains of
crops which will produce higher yields
and be more resistant to climate change
as sam to you first of all do you
welcome the open up of opening up of
gene editing would it be good for the
planet do you think
i do welcome this i think it's a great
opportunity actually which we can take
advantage of outside the eu to introduce
more innovation friendly policy i think
gene editing does have potential for
example to reduce the amount of carbon
intensive fertilizer that we use to grow
crops i think it also potentially will
enable us to grow higher yields on
existing land which means we can leave
more land for for nature and for carbon
sequestration so i think this is a win
for a win for the climate and it's only
the first step but i think there's more
to do the government's going to look at
the wider regulatory regime on gene
editing um but but i strongly welcome it
okay and dave what's your take i mean
george justice the environment secretary
has said it's a tool that could help us
tackle some of the biggest challenges
that we face around food security
are you in agreement with sam and george
eustis
well i think there are
some positives that come up with the
idea of using jumo crops um as sam's
mentioned the nutrition the more
resilience however i do think that we we
need to recognize that there isn't
long-term evidence on how this affects
the environment and this could actually
be tinkering with nature and causing
larger issues than we already face um
there is lots of questions about
biodiversity i'm remembering that in
this you know environmental crisis that
we're facing climate is one part and
that's only one boundary out of the nine
that we have and biodiversity is there
as a very prominent second boundary and
there may be issues around biodiversity
with um following through some of these
scientific technologies
days the government is saying that foods
would only be allowed to be sold if they
were judged that they don't present a
health risk they don't mislead consumers
they don't have a lower nutritional
value does that give you some kind of
reassurance
sadly not really um i feel that the
government has a track record of putting
forward um profit before people's health
and we can see that with things like um
the camera oil field or hs2 um or even
the silvertown tunnel um expansion so
there is that kind of question of can i
truly trust this current government um
to uphold people's well-being before
profit and the answer sadly is no sam
um i think this is quite a cautious move
from the government that all they're
doing is making the research and
development of these uh genetic
varieties of genetically engineered
varieties of crops easier and less
bureaucratic there are still going to be
strong regulatory processes around the
actual selling of these gene edited uh
crop varieties uh in in terms of you
know people's people's supermarket
shopping so you know i think the
government is right to take this step by
step and you know the weight of
scientific evidence i think you know the
the consultation responses they have
from from academics in particular to
show that people think there is no
additional risk from to biodiversity or
to human health from this measure
because it is simply accelerating
processes that have naturally in nature
or indeed through traditional breeding
methods so it's not really introducing
foreign genetic material okay is this
tradition with gm crops we must leave it
there sam hall and days aggie really
good to talk to you both thanks so much
for joining us this evening
do stay tuned